how much would labour want to spend on
defence at the moment
it's hard to fix a firm figure from
opposition you have to have access to
the
secret and confidential military
information on threats on costs on
weapon systems on what the universities
are up to
but labor will always commit what's
needed to defend the country just as we
did over 13 years when we were last in
government when
every year we averaged at least 2.4
percent of gdp in in nato terms what
about a percentage of gdp i mean what
what could you come up with a figure
you can't fix those figures without
access to the information that only
government has but as i said when labor
was in the level of spending that
we had was above what it is now and
the situation in ukraine requires a
response from government
every democracy has to respond when
there are newly realized threats to our
security just as we did after the 9 11
attacks and the twin towers when we
increased
defence spending and brought in the
longest sustained real terms increase
for two decades the money that's being
spent though in ukraine should that be
considered as part of the defense budget
uh it's it's not part of the budget it's
extra money that the treasury is giving
to
the emirates the prime minister's
figures at the moment no
they've said they've confirmed this in
the house of commons these are extra
extra money welcome important essential
to support ukrainians to defend their
country
that military aid from britain has had
labour's full support throughout and
this billion pounds extra today
certainly does as well and how does
labour feel about sweden and finland
joining nato and the appropriate armory
being put on their borders or certainly
on their soil despite what putin's been
saying
well
this is really welcome um
finland and sweden certainly strengthen
nato as a defensive alliance when you
put their fast jets for instance
together with the norwegians that's 250
of the best fighter jets in the world
this will strengthen the whole alliance
it will be
part of the response to the russian
aggression
that we have to live with for the next
decade and
the frustration for me in coming out of
madrid is this that at the time when
you've just reported the nato is
planning an extra 300 000 combat ready
troops
we in britain are set to cut over the
next three years another 10 000 soldiers
from the british army now this is
embarrassing it's not responding to the
growing threats we face
and it is
putting into question
britain's ability to fulfill our nato
obligations when i want britain to
continue to be the leading european
nation within nato and what does that
how does that square up when you see
that we're going to cut 10 000 troops
well
the evidence today is
is clear ben wallace is only able to
commit an extra 1000 troops when nato
plans 300 000 and those are troops that
might not even be based on the border
with russia but back in britain so
i want to see the government do what 14
other countries have already done
since the invasion started which is
reboot our defence planning
review defence spending and reform the
massive waste that goes on in military
procurement at the moment the
government's refusing to do that and
we're lagging behind so to clarify
you're saying
that we should not scrap the extra 10
000 or we should not scrap the 10 000
troops that we're told will be gone in
the next couple of years halt the cuts
uh review the defence plans in light of
the extra threats that we face from
russia for the next decade
review defense spending and above all
get to grips with the broken system of
defense procurement and it isn't just
how much you spend but it's how well you
spend it so this is the government that
has wasted five billion pounds in mod
mis judgment and mismanagement over the
last three years alone but they've got
no plans or any action
to do the deep reform in military
procurement that's needed what do you
make of what the foreign affairs select
committee has been saying that the
british government is allowing russia to
launder dirty money here still
and as a result of basically funding the
war in ukraine
the government should
take that advice and act on their
recommendations it was a foreign affairs
committee an all-party committee foreign
secretary says she doesn't accept it
well
then she's got to have good reason not
to accept it was the foreign affairs
committee that first broke
and provided britain with the evidence
that we had become the center of
laundering dirty money the corrupt money
that keeps putin in power and if this
parliamentary committee is saying
there's more to do
then that's the action the government
should take she says that there is no
country that had acted quicker than the
uk when it came to sanctioning russia
it's not true is it
because the u.s and the european union
put in place sanctions ahead of britain
in some instances because we hadn't even
got the legislation in place and needed
to do that so we were playing catch-up
from the start and neighbor put a good
deal of pressure
as other parties did on government
ministers faster we wanted them to go
further and we wanted to go faster and
if there are still gaps in our sanctions
the day is allowing britain to be still
become
the
place of choice for
those who want to launder corrupt money
especially those around putin to help
keep him in power then we must act where
are you with the front page of the daily
telegraph this morning i'm sure you get
it to deliver to your front door on a
regular basis they're saying that um
this privileges committee headed by
harriet harman is going to be a kangaroo
court against the prime minister and
party gate
i haven't seen the telegraph but this is
a
proper parliamentary committee
doing the proper job in parliament on
behalf of the public
and
harriet harman is mother of the house of
commons she is the longest-serving
female mp in the house of commons she
will act and lead that committee with
utmost probity to do what is a really
important job on behalf of us all so
suggestions that she should not be in
that role nonsense and quite
unacceptable it's for parliament to make
those decisions
and nobody is more conscious
of our parliamentary responsibilities
leave aside party politics
than harriet harman
parliament's decided that babies can't
be in the chamber so working moms can't
bring their babies in the chamber during
um a debate do you think that's
reasonable
well working moms bring their babies
into parliament uh i sat down and had
supper last night with one of our labour
mps and her daughter
about half past seven at night
i think in the chamber it's reasonable
that we
if that's what the speaker decides that
we concentrate on the debates and uh
and make the provision that allows women
mps and fathers if that's necessary
because there are some
dads with young kids that often have to
bring what you're going to do you can't
leave them in central lobby while the
debate's going on can you well
parliament really should be making
provision um for the child care
pretty good at the moment but if it is
if it falls short in some areas then i'm
sure the speaker will want to try and
make sure that isn't the case okay so
you agree with the decision
yes
if that's the decision speaker's taken
about the house of commons chamber then
i'd back that but i'd also say to the
speaker uh if he's not already on the
case well let's make sure there's the
provision in parliament that allows mps
to come into work and do their job okay
let's see what stella creasy has to say
about all of that should we in the
fullness of time can't just leave him
under the stairs can you it's good to
see you as always thank you very much
indeed thank you